und jetzt meine damen und herren sie
haben darauf gewartet reden wir endlich
mal über gülle ja gestern haben in
münster tausende bauern demonstrierten
unter anderem gegen die eu der
deutschlands verschärfte düngeverordnung
noch nicht reicht und ich kann das
verstehen
ich kann ihn wirklich verstehen den
frust unserer landwirte aber mit dem
gleichen recht könnten auch die schweine
auf die straße gehen ja so wie die
allermeisten immer noch gehalten werden
in den stellen und viele tiere heißt
halt viel gülle
seit 1993 gilt schon die europäische
nitrat richtlinie ignoriert von ja fast
sämtlichen landwirtschaftsminister und
jetzt baden auch die kleinbauern aus was
politik und große schweine fabriken an
scheiße baut also im wahrsten sinne des
wortes gülle ist halt ja unangenehm
jetzt darf ich mir mal hier eine prise
nehmen
das stinkt er wirklich extrem glücklich
scheiße richtig gut dass du das
nachrecherchiert hatte
tatsache ist gülle riecht nicht nur
streng sie versaut unser aller
grundwasser 27 prozent der sogenannten
grundwasserkörper sind in einem chemisch
bedenklichen zustand hier auf den roten
flächen ist es ganz schlimm
orange und unbedenklich sind die vielen
hellgrünen flächen die sie da sehen
besonders schlimm ist sie in
niedersachsen hier das neue landes
machen ja
im emsland haben wir es lernen im
emsland zum beispiel da ist der kaffee
morgen schon brauchen bevor er durch
gelaufen
ja unsere wasserversorger schlagen alarm
dass kein witz sie schlagen alarm denn
für sauberes wasser müssen sie in
deutschland immer tiefer bohren deswegen
die das zeug irgendwann immer teurer
nitrat wird im körper zu nitrit und das
ist in höheren dosen leider
krebserregend jetzt droht die eu der
bundesrepublik mit strafzahlungen von
achtung bis zu 800 60.000 euro pro tag
was wir brauchen ist weniger
massentierhaltung und eine
landwirtschaftsministerin die endlich
klartext redet die landwirtschaft
unserer eltern die war anders als die
landwirtschaft ihre eltern also gestern
war gestern heute ist heute aber morgen
wird auch morgen sein
[Musik]
ja sie hat er weg
die schöne müllerin morgen wird auch
morgen sein klingt wie irgendwas von
howard carpendale ja übrigens fürs
protokoll viele bauern in deutschland
wirtschaften längst ökologisch und
kleine höfe sterben bei uns nicht an eu
verordnungen sondern daran dass die
landwirte pro tier einfach viel zu wenig
verdienen ist alles krank dänemark
züchtet ferkel aber zu messen und
kranken bringt man die zu uns ja
deutschland ist die toilette europas da
sind die holländer längst einen guten
schritt weiter sie sind die ersten die
eine toilette benutzen
hier leben skaten dich meine weil es
hier nach kot riecht erklärt peter binz
16 kunden ist dass man wenn man will
dass sie ihr wissen dann muss man so
belohnen das mache ich mit citrix das
ist ja wirklich genau so hat meine frau
mir das auch beigebracht und zitronen
bonbon
[Applaus]
kleiner kleiner unlustiger fun fact am
rande der fleischkonsum geht in
deutschland längst zurück aber trotzdem
haben sich unsere fleisch und milch
exporte nach china in den letzten zehn
jahren fährt 30.8 dafür haben wir
massentierhaltung und die hat folgen
auch für die tiere die immer noch unter
elenden bedingungen kreuz und quer durch
europa gefahren werden hier neue
ehrliche folge von pickel die und
frederik pegel die und frederik standen
im stall und hatten schmerzen frederik
fragte pd warum hat mir denn der bauer
ohne betäubung die einer abgeschnitten
weil du so besser schmeckt sagte
frederik ach so und warum fahren wir
jetzt stundenlang in diesem schweine
engen laster kultige geschichte pickel
die uns fahren sie jetzt in den
schlachthof da töten und zerlegen uns
rumänische billiglöhner die verdienen
pro stunde weniger als du pro kilo
kostet hh lachte pg g das sind ja arme
schweine gerichts aber gar nicht gut
frederik sagte pd und was hat der mann
lakonisch ist in der hand gute frage die
das ist ein bolzenschussgerät damit kann
man und pickel die ging mit frederik
zerteilt und tiefgekühlt nach jena ende
ja und morgen liebe traumatisierte
kinder grillen wir dann schauen das
schaf leider leider hat die strengere eu
gülle verordnung eine unschöne
nebenwirkungen gülle tourismus und damit
meine ich nicht ferien auf dem bauernhof
sondern immer mehr stinkende transporter
auf unseren straßen statistisch
passieren in deutschland jede woche zwei
unfälle mit gülle das ist
brandgefährlich fürs grundwasser das
zeug wird aus besonders belasteten
regionen in noch unbelastete gekarrt und
wohl auch immer wieder illegal entsorgt
besonders gern im sauerland wir schalten
wir live an einen parkplatz bei brilon
zu heike stockhaus seine firma auf
solche transporte spezialisierter stock
aus sie kippten die gülle dabei nicht
einfach irgendwohin oder was sie so
natürlich nicht illegal aber sie müssen
lauter sprechen für die atomkraftgegner
aus hier ist fernsehen machen sie wenn
ich ins hemd herr welke das zeug
verteilt sich hier geht das so ein hügel
runter und da unten fängt auch schon das
spaßbad an
sie können mir vertrauen ich bin scheiße
trucker in dritter generation
bombengeschäft 2017 hat allein
nordrhein-westfalen 1,39 millionen
tonnen braunes gold aus holland
importiert tröpfchen für tröpfchen
qualität
wir überschreiten die nitratwerte und
holen uns da noch zusätzlich in gülle
aus holland
warum ja wie warum für geld außerdem in
den niederlanden wird von der polizei
regelrecht kontrolliert wo viel gülle
hipster werden gülle laster mit gps
verfolgt hier in nrw sind insgesamt 20
hynix von der landwirtschaftskammer für
die kontrolle zuständig ich würde mal
sagen das schreiten gebraucht
lustig ohne ein drittel der gülle
lieferung nach nrw sind falsch
deklariert die gehen unternehmen an
bauernhöfe die es gar nicht gibt ja auch
britischen pfundes immer ich fahre
manchmal mit 20 schon los im komm mit
einer an
da ist ja oft fahrtwind und natürlich
gehen auch mal ein zwei tropfen beim
einfüllen verloren lässt sich gar nicht
vermeiden
scheiße der ganze laden gestellt
das ist ein job für fachkräfte da kannst
du nicht jeden nehmen ja also wird das
so weitergehen mit dem gülle tourismus
ja sorry handy deutschen kino matt für
199 wollen dann müssen sie wohl mit den
konsequenzen leben
dazu hatte ich eine tolle geschäftsidee
für die ganzen städter die immer auf dem
biohof einkaufen liebe zuschauer
übernehmen sie jetzt eine gülle
patenschaft für nur 50 euro im monat
schicken wir ihnen jeden tag eine
frische kühle box nach hause
so frisch wie es noch warm und sie
entsorgen die dann für uns im
zimmerpflanzen oder keine ahnung kippen
sie von mir aus ins kloster egal
jeder kann mithelfen beim einer aktion
sos kühle tor
so und jetzt muss ich weitermachen und
das kinderbecken das fühlt sich nicht
von allein
schweiß den riemen auf die orgel
stockhausen damen und herren klickt hier
für weitere heute schon videos und
klickt im moment
und klickt hier um den channel zu
abonnieren
[Musik]